you
yes and no so if this health reform bill
goes through and I I think it's looking
like every sign will it is about health
reform but not reforming health care
which is what we really need meaning
redesigning health care to be better
quality better safety lower-cost getting
rid of wasted unnecessary steps and
moves and the harmful components of care
it has the experiments in it to be able
to start having us try to innovate on
the on that systems level so when we've
talked about innovation in medicine what
we've usually meant is will there be a
new drug will we have the cure for
cancer and we are on our way with or
without reform to spending 18 19 perhaps
even twenty percent of our whole economy
on health care there there's no shortage
of money for those kinds of innovations
and I think those fields will prosper
but to take advantage of them and be
sure we're using them in every community
in the right way at the right time we
have not been innovating I think if
health reform doesn't pass that we will
be very slow to innovate but there are
components in the health reform package
that includes innovations both at that
front end trying to design say the
checklists for the right kind of care
and also on the incentives end that is
one of the reasons we don't come up with
these kinds of checklists is that
hospitals and doctors don't do better
financially when they put in these kinds
of tools for example Children's Hospital
in Boston came up with a checklist for
asthma patients children who are
severely asthmatic enough to end up
admitted to the hospital and they
recognize that a couple of components
were key making phone calls to the
families to make sure the children were
taking their inhalers and having a look
at the
apartments to make sure that or homes to
make sure that dust and mites were not a
problem in the homes by tackling just
those two things they reduced admissions
for kids with asthma by eighty-seven
percent but asthma was their number one
admission to Children's Hospital and
they found this experiment lost the
millions of dollars and so they suddenly
were face to face with well maybe we
need to shut down this program in order
to survive as a hospital that's when you
know there's just something wrong with
the way we are designing our system and
the reform bill we don't know what is
the best way to pay that hospital so
that it does the right thing but we have
some good ideas about the experiments to
try one is for example paying the
doctors and hospital together whether
that kid is admitted to the hospital or
not so that they're on the same page
about taking care of this kid with
asthma the kid with asthma might get
pulling a number out at five thousand
dollars for that diagnosis and care in
that year and so let's simply give that
money and then have them work to try to
make the best of that financial
situation which i think leads can lead
to better care
the Massachusetts system is coverage we
went from twelve percent uninsured to
two percent uninsured and that's very
impressive European countries are at 98
to ninety nine percent coverage of their
populations and Massachusetts did it
without with most of the people in the
population not even noticing it was
through a private coverage insurance if
you are uninsured or can't afford
insurance coverage you can go on the web
and get subsidized insurance policies
that limit your costs to about eight
percent of your income not everybody's
happy about that if you're only earning
thirty thousand dollars a year and have
twenty four hundred dollars that's eight
percent to have to pay that seems like a
lot but insurance premiums are typically
fifteen or sixteen percent of people's
income so this it's heavily subsidized
the downside cost there was nothing in
the Massachusetts plan to deal with
costs now the costs have not contrary to
many of the news reports have not
outstripped the budget the Massachusetts
health care costs have continued to rise
about eight percent or so per year which
is right in the middle of where the
country's costs have been rising and the
program for the uninsured actually came
in under budget if the recession hadn't
dropped the bottom out of tax revenues
than this would have gone on is if there
were no issues at all but the pressure
of the loss of that tax revenue led the
hospitals and doctors and insurers to
actually be serious about cost controls
and I'd say in the state were a couple
years ahead of other places in starting
to try innovations paying doctors and
hospitals differently instead of
fee-for-service just being paid for
every time you do an operation for
example there's a shift towards saying
let's pay for results and let's figure
out how to do it so that kind of pay for
results system is now being tested and
experimented with though it's still not
easy to figure out
the national reform package actually
looks a lot like the Massachusetts
package it has coverage through private
insurers that people would get to choose
from go on the web and sign up for a
health plan if you don't have coverage
or can't afford it there's more in the
bill to do with trying to control the
costs and that is also a plus there's
more in there than we see in
Massachusetts by far some of it is to
try to really drive insurance
competition by for example having
insurers pay premium tax if their
insurance plans come to cost more than
23 thousand dollars a year most plans
are far from costing that much right now
but they're on their way to doing it if
they don't figure out how to organize
better second though is whether its
private insurance or federal programs
like Medicare there are very interesting
experiments pilot programs to test out
paying doctors in different ways from
the way we've done it for example paying
a hospital system that actually
encompasses both hospital care and
outpatient care a what they call
gainsharing if they bring their costs
down the Medicare program would let them
keep half of the reduction in costs to
try to provide an incentive for
controlling costs as long as they meet
basic quality control measures and have
good access to primary care kennel
hospitals actually learn to do this can
we organize to get our act together I
think the answer is going to depend on
their adopting things like checklists
for the most costly and harmful
conditions where we see a lot of
mistakes and waste but this is tough
stuff doctors and hospitals are quite
fragmented very disorganized and
learning how to really work as a system
of people is going to take us it's not
going to be a matter of two or three
years this is going to be a generational
effort but i think the clear signs are
we can first end up reducing just the
rate of inflation but then over time if
we are able to learn and use the lessons
we could even bring the cost down which
has been feasible in other lines of work